c'est un bien triste anniversaire qu'on
célébrait les familles des victimes de
l'écrasement du vol
ps752 en janvier 2020 l'avion a été
abattu quelques minutes seulement après
avoir décollé de l'aéroport de Téhéran
par deux missiles lancés par des membres
du corps des Gardiens de la Révolution
islamique de l'Iran 85 canadiens et
résidents en permanents ont perdu la vie
plus de 1000 jours plus tard leur
famille attendent toujours que justice
soit faite ça doit être beaucoup de
force partie de gouvernement au Canada
de aller forcer
le régime iranien pour avoir le vérité
Armin Morata a perdu son frère jumeau et
sa belle-sœur dans la tragédie et malgré
le temps qui passe la douleur est
toujours aussi vive on a eu beaucoup de
belles moments ensemble
notre vie a changé beaucoup dans son
discours le Premier ministre Justin
Trudeau s'est engagée à faire en sorte
que la République islamique rendent des
comptes pour l'écrasement du vol ps752
on va continuer d'être là pour demander
des comptes au régime iranien une
promesse que cette célèbre journaliste
et militante iranienne en exil leur
exhorté à tenir action nous avons besoin
de votre action où il y a-t-elle lancé
en décembre le Canada la Suède de
l'Ukraine et le Royaume-Uni ont
déclenché un processus officiel pour
tenir l'Iran légalement responsable de
l'écrasement du Boeing ils veulent que
les rangs se soumettent à un arbitrage
contraignant pour que la République
islamique soit tenue légalement
responsable de la tragédie c'est les
parties ne s'accordent pas sur
l'organisation de l'arbitrage au cours
des six prochains mois
Ottawa s'adressera à la Cour
internationale de justice
[Musique]
sans compter distanctions que nous avons
annoncé à l'encontre des personnes
responsables de la destruction de
l'avion assure le ministre fédéral des
Transports même s'il n'a pas confiance
en le régime iranien Armin Morata garde
espoir
il espère que le soulèvement de son
peuple en Iran au cours des derniers
mois fera tomber le régime iranien la
seule manière selon lui que justice soit
faite il Sandra nous Williams
Radio-Canada Toronto